la subcomisión de acusaciones
constitucionales del Congreso de Perú ha
aprobado el informe que recomienda
acusar constitucionalmente al
expresidente Pedro Castillo como autor
de los delitos de organización criminal
agravada tráfico de influencias Y
colusión en este proceso también están
incluidos los exministros heiner
Alvarado y Juan Silva pero para que todo
esto surja efecto se requiere que el
informe sea traslado a la comisión
permanente esta a su vez en los
siguientes días va a programar una
sesión donde se va a debatir y se va a
votar en la aprobación de este reporte y
una vez que esto acontezca será traslado
a la comisión permanente una vez que la
mejor dicho el parlamento el pleno del
parlamento peruano tenga esto aprobado
va a dar pie a que la fiscalía tenga la
total libertad de llevar a Pedro
Castillo a una corte para afrontar estos
delitos que se le está acusando
Aunque todavía entonces se continúan por
o están por verse las consecuencias ya
ha habido algunas porque la presidenta
Dina boluarte hizo una locución en la
que se refirió a los muertos que viven
las protestas a la intervención de
algunos países latinoamericanos y a
posibles nuevas manifestaciones qué fue
lo que dijo la mandataria
Sí justamente como usted lo señala María
Clara la presidenta boluarte acaba de
anunciar que va a otorgar toda la
facilidades a la fiscalía peruana para
que investigue las muertes que se han
producido debido de estas protestas hay
que señalar que de diversos sectores del
Perú y diversos colectivos sociales
están acusando que ha habido un excesivo
uso de la fuerza por parte de la policía
y las fuerzas algunos miembros de las
fuerzas armadas la mandataria peruana
quiere dar total transparencia al caso y
ha sido enfática en señalar que se va a
dar toda la facilidades al ministerio
público también indina boluarte ha dicho
que ha tomado conocimiento debido a
reportes de los servicios de
inteligencia que las protestas se van a
reanudar el 4 de enero En diversas
regiones del país Dina boluarte está
enfatizando el despliegue de sus
ministros a estas regiones para tratar
de establecer mesas de diálogo la
mandataria peruana también quiere que
los países de la región puedan tener un
mejor conocimiento y contacto de lo que
ha sucedido en Perú
juicio ha habido una mala interpretación
de algunos países de América por eso es
que los diplomáticos peruanos van a
tratar de establecer el diálogo y
explicaciones para retomar una agenda
normalidad con Perú y sus vecinos